im laufe unseres aufenthaltes in wiener
neustadt gab es dann noch einen befehl
in einer art demonstration zu zeigen was
unsere panzerfahrer trennen und das vor
den versammelten militärattachés
hauptsächlich der vier siegermächte das
ganze fand im raum katzelsdorf statt und
bestand im überwinden von
geländehindernissen und eines der
schwersten hindernisse war eine art
panzergraben als erstes wurde ein
amerikanischer panzer vom typ m 24
bestimmt dieses hindernis zu durch
wurden und den gegenüberliegenden hang
zu gewinnen
unglücklicherweise hat man hier einen
panzer mit gummi ketten ausgewählt und
der panzer kam auch nicht durch er
scheiterte kläglich
als nächstes wurde mir befohlen mit
meinem typ 34 jetzt auch diese übung
durchzuführen und mein panzerfahrer
müller meisterte die aufgabe bravourös
ich sagte ganz langsam kommen lassen
rauf auf den hang und oben etwas wippen
das geschah und jetzt kommt eine kleine
episode die schildern es wert ist
der sowjetische militär steht mit einem
breiten grinsen deutete zum jahr auf
rutschen car show sagte er
so sehr gut und tätschelte mit einer
freundlichen gäste den druck meines t 34
ich blickte in diesem moment auch zum
amerikanischen militärattaché der mann
war blut rot angelaufen